schlagen und dann doch überrascht werden
vom echten leben
ich komme zur welt als die mauer fällt
und mandela aus dem gefängnis geleast
wird die sex pistols über klebig mit den
backstreet boys und richtig touch war
ich eigentlich nur beim tod von lady di
dabei ist draußen seit zehn jahren dauer
krisen nur an uns ist das irgendwie
vorbei gezogen und das leben schreibt
du kannst alles erreichen wir sind die
generation krise
alles kann nichts muss der auftakt von
dominik loches film tempo girl
beschreibt das umfeld seiner generation
in einer multi options- gesellschaft
egal ob baby oder krise das etikett
spielt keine rolle dafür die eigene
lebenserfahrung und auch wenn diese mit
31 jahren überschaubar ist für die
abschlussarbeit seines studiums spielte
sie eine zentrale rolle
einfach vor mirós gange
und vor fünf jahren unbedingt erfolg
will ich denke das gibt mir irgendeine
form von selbst oder anerkennung als
erfolg im sinn von könig wieso traffic
sie verdammen und nachher st velen figur
gemacht
möchtegern autoren dominik führt in
berlin ein unstetes hipster leben als
ihr manuskript vom verleger wegen
mangelnder authentizität verrissen wird
tut es zum ersten mal richtig weh im
ganzen haus einem arschloch riesch
trucks auf der suche nach dem wahren
leben hat sie kurz entschlossen ab mit
dennis zufallsbekanntschaft und döner
verkäufer gewinnst es wirklich
durchziehen einen plan haben die beiden
nicht stattdessen lassen sie den zufall
entscheiden und landen in abgelegenen
weiß
sich vom leben treiben lassen und
trotzdem seine ziele verfolgen
in einer multi options- gesellschaft ein
schwieriger balanceakt auch noch erkennt
fluch und segen der fast unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten die qual der wahl
beruflich wie privat viele optionen
offen laut und lauter verbaue dann so
viele touristische zum beispiel der trip
aus ihrer konfession bringt die junge
autorin näher an die realität und gibt
ihr stoff für ein nächstes buch keine
ahnung warum gerade dennis ich meine
dittmann ist jetzt echt nicht gerade to
play
aber es war wahrscheinlich genau das war
also dicke eier hat darum hat ihre
abenteuerlust steht sie auf der bühne
eines drittklassigen striplokal grenz
erfahrungen als mittel zum erfolg geben
denn nur wer etwas erlebt kann auch
darüber schreiben
neben dem selbstfindungstrip eines
hipsters schneidet tempo girl auch
bedeutende themen des lebens an die
liebe demütigung verlust
die geschichte überzeugt genauso wie die
schauspieler und die reise der
protagonistin zahlt sich am ende aus
auch noch das abenteuer hat sich gelohnt
nicht nur beruflich hat der
bodenständige walliser seinen weg
gefunden
probiere das sammer für die mega wichtig
und felix günstig aber das war egal
kollege global wenn der kulturrat trotz
allem hipster der habe sehnen sich autor
wie filmfigur nach traditionellen werten
vielleicht wählt diese generation trotz
oder gerade wegen der schier unendlichen
möglichkeiten am ende den weg
wer schon immer da war